so today's topic domestic workers abuse
in the Middle East but may know that
Sally that's fact one of the most
shocking cases of murders in 2014 when a
sri lankan made return from Saudi Arabia
with 24 nails inside her body the woman
alleged that her Saudi employer had
routine tortured her and drove nails
into her body as punishment earlier this
month King Abdullah pardoned an
Indonesian maid who was sentenced to
death in 2003 after being convicted of
witchcraft what was you doing reading
Harry Potter what the [ __ ] was she doing
I know what happened her her employer
was beating her up and then gave her one
of these in this video which emerged on
YouTube in early March
shows the moment Ethiopian migrant
worker our lamb of the chassis was
dragged along the street and they moved
[Applause]
shortly after this footage was recorded
she was taken to hospital where she
apparently hung herself our lambs
partner Lamesa ashita remembers the
moment he and their two children said
goodbye
mashaallah yo self is an uber cannon
Walter the Gadhafi original Brussels
Amata Nagar region major Rashad
my area meteorologist at g10 usually
America each year Sarah on TV time she
you thought it was Pedro for mono
McCadden because a lot a rich the
Americas it an America's credit nothing
would in a touch what I did to be arnica
gradually someone does he say last
Manila Luigi Nitish yeah
I know people who would see that and be
like well you know she sure to listen to
her to her master it's one of the things
that made me the most uncomfortable
going back to Lebanon where I'm from
mm-hmm and I always identified as very
Lebanese and I felt so attached that I
did that identity and as soon as I went
there I was like oh man I'm Canadian his
[ __ ] just even just seeing that people
had maids just the fact even when they
were treated well you know I had one
family member who did it have it made
for me to Ethiopian she seemed to be
treated well which was part of the
family it still felt so disgusting even
though she's cool she's open she's
almost like a nun obviously there's
there's gotta be there's limits there's
limits it's like when you're accepted
into a family like that yes we're given
some leeway and some special privileges
and then who treats you well it's nice
to know but there are limits and you
also know what those limits are if you
were to talk back let's say and a person
for others they're all the cellulite
know your place yeah right and so it's a
weird environment where everyone gets
along and they smile but you're not
allowed to do certain things because of
color your skin and your place in
society
exactly and the fact that I knew that
made me so uncomfortable I know that
there's invisible shackles on your
wrists right now yeah I mean yeah it's
it's slavery there's no other way around
if you hold people against their will if
you give them no ability to leave if you
withhold their paint which is a lot of
them are not being paid for the work
that they're doing if you physically and
sexually abused them and there's no
repercussions for that abuse then what
would you call it other than sleep
so there's a this [ __ ] makes video
some face is a good word
her name is Santos Santos that's why
I've never heard that's probably like a
million Arab people being like this for
her to take a day off every week that's
four days a month those are the days
that she'll be out so we don't know what
she'll be doing on those days with her
passport on her maybe to create an
environment where she would want to run
away you would be so worried about yeah
that's a very good point what do human
rights have to do with the worker
keeping her passport even our kids don't
hold onto their passport you see it a
child and you think you're not ready to
make any decisions for yourself I have
to do everything for you you're gonna do
as I say and to look at another adult
and see that same thing is telling of
your entire mindset well how can this be
wrong I've been doing it for 25 years
[ __ ] you've been wrong for 25 yes I
know when she made that comment there
were other people around her proof read
it because influencers have a team right
and so they read that one that looks
good you're good
what's next we give him food how are you
gonna sleep who's gonna calm your
eyebrows everybody everybody hasn't made
any family who has any bit of money
talking like upper middle class middle
class families don't have a drive of
ever cook they'll have somebody take
care of the kid it's part of the culture
just written into the culture to become
so normal hmm then of course you're
gonna have people like this you will say
in Lebanon people will say like I'm the
city lanky I have a Sri Lankan and a
Filipina like I think it's literally a
holidays I have a parade
yes yes it's written into the language
okay and still the derogatory word
towards black people is slave one of my
best friends growing up was a Sri Lankan
dude I just mentioned that when I was
like 18 - my friends are like my best
friends - sure like a sri lankan
mentioned - my cousins in Lebanon they
were kinda like Oh what do you mean like
if you're friends with the Sri Lankan I
mean I grew up in a Muslim family and
I'd always dealt with far more racism
coming from there
people at it from any other racial group
I myself am NOT Muslim but I always see
it everywhere but then you remember that
the most renowned prophet you know in
the book is Musa and he's extremely dark
do you wanna say so you have prophets
are dark skin that these people will
sing about and chant about in their
prayer groups but then they will treat
other fellow looking black people like
absolute trash and to Arab people's
credit you know if they're gonna marry
their daughters they're gonna hate the
idea of marrying to us to any other Arab
group because it's pretty tribal like
tribalistic like that but then along
racial lines it gets even more intense
and so on one hand there's our desire in
me to wanna fight these lava phobia on
the other it's weird to fight for people
that would prefer killing their
daughters over letting them marry me you
know who say do you know yeah absolutely
that's the people who claim to be the
most pious in the most righteous you
know the most vile you conservative
Christians the most antique it was
always the most
anti-gay pastor yeah but it's like oh
and then they find him three weeks later
like a senator Johnson how did you fit
all those those Puerto Rican dicks in
your mouth all nine of them like the
Lord helped me in Israel mm-hmm you know
Leo Pia have been around since 400 years
after Jesus Christ to this day
Israelis dislike a lot Ethiopian Jews
and Ethiopians in general and the few
isolated Israelis who dared to protest
like this woman or met with harsh
backlash
Lebanese friends will talk about how you
know African migrants are treated in
Israel thing look on that issue on that
issue look at your own house it's no
different I know I'm seeing the way I
grew up in my perspective is superior
yeah they're treating other people with
equality and respect then yeah your
point of view is superior to somebody
who treats other humans like children as
the girl there are certain aspects of a
culture that you shouldn't accept just
because it's culture doesn't mean it's
like have to be Munn touched right if
you know what they could've easily said
that owning black people was part of
American culture this is definitely some
that Springer holding passports not
allowing people to leave abusing them
dropping them from the seventh floor and
watching them plummet and laughing these
are all things that I can look like no
it's not a culture thing you're just a
piece of [ __ ] you with me and we have to
be able to have that conversation I just
hope that people in the name of
protecting culture don't overlook this
kind of abuse because it has tremendous
effects and long lasting scars for a lot
of other families and a lot of people
are suffering at the hands of this abuse
I just think it's human beings we always
want to do better and if I say this is
not because I want to put people down I
just think the Gulf can do better I
think we could all do better someone
from Ethiopia who has to hear about
these stories of Ethiopian maids it's
very hard to have these conversations
and we have to be able to have that
conversation or else more people are
going to get abuse more people are gonna
die because everyone wants to be PC and
be like its culture this is not to say
that the entirety of the culture in the
Middle East is inferior or it or is it
evil no relatively there's aspects of
the culture that need to change the only
thing you do really to make any change
in the world is change yourself at least
start to look inward and so table soon I
forgive you
I think there's a give me a glass of
wine you just gonna be glass water if
possible you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
Lisi so that's it for today's interview
guys like that leave your comments below
we won the world you think about this
did you ever show having October 12th
links below for that give up soda
withdraw
[Music]